the 1990s brought the world some truly
incredible tv
but for every network sitcom that played
it safe there were shows with premises
that were frankly
bonkers from the alien abduction capers
to the sci-fi cowboy romps
these are the 90s shows with the
weirdest setups around
twin peaks made its debut on april 8
1990
and forever changed the way television
shows were made received and discussed
created by mark frost and david lynch
the series focuses on the killing of
popular high school student
laura palmer in the fictional town of
twin peaks washington
the ensuing investigation led by fbi
special agent dale cooper
brings forth a seemingly endless number
of suspects from the town's pool of
eccentrics
and is marked by supernatural
occurrences doppelgangers housed in
extra dimensional realms and
otherworldly killers the show blends
elements from nearly every genre
balancing its serious subject matter
with its own that's both irreverent and
melodramatic
who's the lady with the log i would call
it a long leg
lynch's cinematic vision came from so
far out of left
field that the complete absurdity of it
made viewers a head spin
the twists and turns of the show's
narrative are dizzying teenage
prostitution
riddle spouting giants drug trafficking
and the afterlife itself
are all part of the twin peaks story no
wonder we're still discussing it more
than 30 years after its debut
from the moment the x-files premiered in
1993 it was obvious viewers were going
to be in for one hell of a ride
its pilot episode centers on a series of
teenage deaths that fbi special agents
fox mulder and dana scully are tasked
with solving
mulder is convinced that they're the
result of alien abductions
while scully believes there's a rational
explanation to be found
do you believe in the existence of
extraterrestrials
logically i would have to say no
the truth is that there's more to it
than either agent realizes which
sends the pair on an 11 season long
quest to uncover the government's
darkest secrets
along with its heavy dose of ufo lore
the x-files explores everything from a
cult mystery to cyberpunk sci-fi
highlights of the series include season
2's humbug
which tells the story of a killer
parasitic twin let loose among a
community of circus performers
season 3's clyde bruckman's final repose
about a life insurance salesman who can
see how people will die and who gives
scully a couple of very important
predictions
and season four's at home arguably the
show's most controversial episode which
follows the peacocks a very texas
chainsaw-esque family
living and breeding in a small
pennsylvania town it's wild it's weird
and it's why we still love the x-files
today
in the spring of 1989 television
audiences were blessed with the glorious
seaside camp fest that was
baywatch starring david hasselhoff as
mitch buchanan
the series follows a team of la county
lifeguards as they dive headfirst into
hard-hitting stories
like stomping an amateur fire breather
from burning down lifeguard towers and
inadvertently falling in love with
killers
the show wound up being so successful
that it got a spin-off in 1995
baywatch knights which takes the
ridiculous premise of crime-fighting
lifeguards to a whole new level
baywatch knights follows garner ellerbee
a police sergeant turned private
detective who starts a business with
mitch and detective ryan mcbride
the first season is pretty standard
stuff but when ratings dipped the show
took a sharp
left into x-files territory replacing
garner with paranormal
expert diamond teague in season two from
there
fast food drug deals and mob kidnappings
were replaced with haitian voodoo cults
vampires and gelatinous sea monsters the
supernatural update did little to solve
the show's viewership issues though and
it was canceled after its sophomore
season
photojournalist thomasvale's life is
turned upside down
when in the middle of a romantic dinner
with his wife he returns from the
bathroom to find that his entire
existence has been erased
his wife is gone his best friend is dead
and there's someone else living in his
house
nowhere man follows thomas's quest to
uncover the truth of his stolen identity
which traces back to a secret government
organization
and a photograph he took of four u.s
soldiers being hanged in south america
everything they give you they can take
back everything you thought you had you
don't
absolute zero gentle jack bottom line
it ran for one season before it was
canceled the series plays out much like
1963's the fugitive
and that thomas travels from city to
city in search for clues about the
organization
picking up odd jobs to fly under the
radar while he gets closer to the truth
along the way he comes into contact with
a string of strange characters
including a 10 year old blind psychic a
ufo enthusiast
and several actors hired by the
organization to bring thomas in
ultimately the truth behind the
organization and thomas's lost identity
leaves him with more questions than
answers
but with the show's early cancellation
audiences were never given the
opportunity to delve any deeper
mantis's pilot episode is vastly
different from the series that follows
it begins as the story of one of the
first black superheroes on tv
dr miles hawkins a biophysicist who
becomes paralyzed after being shot by a
police sniper during a riot
he develops an exoskeleton that offers
him mobility and more
the mechanically augmented
neurotransmitter interactive system
and rather reluctantly sets out on a
mission to fight crime and corruption
before the series went to air however
serious changes were made
including the replacement of its diverse
cast with one that featured only two
people of color outside the show's main
character
plot points that focused heavily on
racial issues were changed in favor of
fantasy elements like parallel universes
and time travel
the series finale involves an invisible
dinosaur frozen in a glacier
this retooled concept was met with
criticism
although network execs were quick to
cite creative reasons for the changes
with bob greenblatt
senior vice president of drama series
development at fox telling the los
angeles times
i thought the pilot was too grim and too
realistic we didn't want to do episodes
about the human condition every week
so instead audiences got genetically
altered jellyfish people
the 1978 cult classic attack of the
killer tomatoes has
undoubtedly one of the most ridiculous
premises in cinematic history
giant man-eating tomatoes descend upon
the country throwing it into chaos
the only hope for humanity lies with a
group of ragtag heroes led by a man
named mason dixon
that includes a disguise expert who
attempts to infiltrate the tomatoes by
dressing as one of them say well
somebody please pass the ketchup
victory comes from a ballad called
puberty love it'd be difficult to build
upon that premise any further
but between 1990 and 1991 fox kids did
exactly that with
attack of the killer tomatoes the
animated series no one saw coming
five years after the great tomato war dr
putrid t
gangrene has continued his tomato
experiments
which now include tomato variants like
tara
a tomato turned human and her dog ft
a fuzzy tomato that barks tara befriends
chad our 10 year old hero and gets a job
working at chad's uncle's shop
tomatoes pizza parlor together the trio
attempt to stop gang green from taking
over the world
who then work alongside him to defeat a
group of twice mutated tomatoes and
revolt
it's just as weird as it sounds but
still not the weirdest thing that 90s
kids were exposed to
executively produced by sam raimi
american gothic is a horror drama that
ran on cbs for one season between 1995
and 1996. it tells the story of caleb
temple
a young boy in the fictional town of
trinity south carolina who comes to find
out he's the son of the literal devil
who rules over the town by posing as its
friendly sheriff lucas buck
after lucas kills caleb's entire family
he sets about grooming him to take over
the throne
only two roads in this world and if
you're listening to anyone but me
you're on the wrong one but he stopped
with the help of trinity's newest
transplant dr matt crower
caleb's cousin gail and the ghost of his
sister merlin
that plot is strange enough as it is but
cbs pulled a firefly with the series and
aired the season out of order
cutting four episodes completely from
its original run as a result
some key moments wound up being omitted
from the story including the one in
which gail uncovers the truth behind her
parents mysterious deaths
and another in which lucas enlists the
help of the boston strangler's ghost to
deal with merlin
on the planet luminaire the forces of
good and evil fight for control of the
powerful lightstar crystal
on one side is baron dark whose success
in capturing one half of the crystal has
turned him into a living skeleton
with the ability to change others into
skeletons for his army
on the other side is price light star in
his family who've managed to hold on to
the other half of the light star crystal
which has imbued each of them with
fantastic and decidedly less skeletonly
powers i have the power to terrify small
children and straight dogs
skeleton warriors ran for only 13
episodes on cbs between 1994 and 1995.
things change on a dime in luminaire one
week baron dark would have the upper
hand
then the next week it would belong to
prince lightstar
the show ends with baron dark's defeat
and the destruction of the lightstar
crystal entirely
while the story never evolves beyond the
power struggle at its core
it did spawn its very own toy line a
marvel comic series
and a video game proving that it didn't
take much to keep 90s kids entertained
given a cool enough aesthetic skeleton
warriors exists today as an artifact
from a bizarre time in
animation part misty fantasy part steely
sci-fi
heart death metal t-shirt the 90s had a
real fascination with the idea of
virtual reality
films like 1992's the lawnmower man
1995's johnny mnemonic
and 1999's the 13th floor all explore
the virtual realm
complete with cutting edge computer
graphics straight out of tomb raider
now these kinds of sequences look pretty
laughable but in 1995
they were extremely cool vr5 is the
embodiment of that trend
from its dramatic shots of people typing
to its cyberpunk visors
the show follows sydney bloom a line
worker for a telephone company who
dabbles in virtual reality in her off
time
when she accidentally discovers that she
has the ability to tap into other's
subconscious through her own vr world
sydney becomes the target of the
committee a secret organization that may
have actually been behind her family's
death years prior
welcome to the game sydney bloom vr5
didn't last
long only 13 episodes total with three
of them not airing at all during the
show's run on fox
but in those 13 episodes audiences were
treated to implanted memories
mirror worlds and a whole lot of bad cg
wild west cowboys of mumesa ran on abc
for two seasons between 1992 and 1993.
like most animated kids shows at the
time the series premise is completely
bonkers
when a mysterious comet hits the
southwest sometime during the 19th
century
it forms a mesa high in the clouds where
its inhabitants become
helmetized mutating into a race of cow
people
whose way of life is strikingly similar
to the regular human cowboys that exist
below
keeping peace in this bovine territory
are the code of the west boys
a group of lawmen led by marshall moo
montana that includes the dakota dude
and the colorado kid the cowboys fight
back against a series of villains
led by mayor oscar bulani and sheriff
terrorball
drop them huh
[Music]
yeah for the most part the cowboys deal
with pretty standard wild west fare
cattle drives oil strikes and masked
robberies
but the show occasionally delved into
even weirder territory
the 90s truly were a wonderful time to
be alive
even if you were a cow check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite 90s stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you